ومن الاردن سالنا الناس برايك من هو
المسؤول في زواج القاصرات نتابع الاجابات
المسؤول الاول والاخير الاهل لانه القاصره
يعني معلوماتها بكون بالنسبه للزواج او
للحياه بتكون يعني محدوده
فالمسؤول الاول والاخير الاهل الاهل لانه
لازم الاهل يكونوا مسؤولين على اولادهم
باي شيء ايا كان ان كان اشي صعب ان كان
زواج ان كان دراسه ان كان تعليم ان كان
فيهم ان كان جهل وبتصفى الاولاد نسبه يعني
40% انه هو كمان انه يكون عقل بيفهم بعرف
شو بعمل ايش اللي لمصلحته ايش صح ايش غلط
اول اشي الحاله الاجتماعيه اللي بمر فيها
والد القاصر بيتجه انه يزوجها يخلص من
مصاريف البيت الزائده من زواجها ومهرها
اللي بيكون هو ما يترتب عليه والد الزوج
انه بيحصل عليه ظروف الحياه صعبه
وفي الجهل للاولاد الامور ولا بدنا نسكر
البنت بالاساس كلها بترجع لظروف
الحياه هلا المسؤول عن زواج القاصرات اكثر
شي هن اولياء الامور او المجتمع اللي
بيفرض حاله على اولياء الامور واقعنا
ومجتمعنا عرفت علي